So I'm going to go more broad during the talk and just tell you what I think are critical
things in designing a frontline clinical trial that incorporates menin inhibitor to standard
of care treatments.
So you've seen this multiple times now.
Menin inhibitors are a new class of drug.
They affect epigenetic regulation.
They disrupt the binding of menin to KMT2A, cause differentiation and anti-leukemic effect.
And the main genotypes that are being tested or used, menin inhibitors are used for are
KMT2A rearranged leukemias, which is likely 5% of acute leukemias, 5 to 10%, and NPM1
is 25 to 30%.
So that's the first conundrum in designing a study.
KMT2A is not common.
So designing a frontline study for KMT2A is going to be challenging to be powered unless
it's included with the NPM1 subset that would drive the primary objective.
So most trials are using that strategy or even separating the KMT2A and not doing a
full randomized study.
Also to have the lay of the land, to understand what is the standard of care.
So for young FIT, the standard of care, if FLT3 mutant, we're going to make a distinction
between FLT3 positive, so all mutations, mydastorin, or FLT3 FLT3-quizartinib.
And the cutoff that is used here is based on the trial that led to approval of quizartinib,
so EVAF more than 3%.
So any trial that's going to be testing a menin inhibitor cannot be incorporating a population
for which a FLT3 inhibitor is the standard.
So majority are going to do an eligibility below 3% FLT3.
The TKDs is probably more of a question mark, especially that they may benefit from menin
inhibition.
Take away from this slide, eligibility, if we're designing a young FIT trial, has to
be NPM1, FLT3, mostly wild type, or FLT3 less than 3%.
For older unfit, the standard of care is AZA/VEN.
There's no distinction in this case for FLT3, even though there's growing data that FLT3
mutations affect prognosis and maybe the addition of FLT3 inhibitor improves outcomes.
But for now, this is standard.
So it is a straightforward AZA/VEN plus or minus menin inhibitor.
We also have to understand the expected outcomes.
So for NPM1 and newly diagnosed AML, they do really well as a relative when you look
at the myeloma data.
They do well for AML people, which is a response rate that is high, 90% roughly, and a five-year
survival that is with a median of 88%.
So this is lumping FLT3 plus NPM1, the NPM1 not FLT3 co-mutated do a little better.
But nevertheless, we are dealing with an endpoint, if it is EFS, that would happen much longer
and is going to, if we're testing the addition of a drug, it's going to be hopefully a large
benefit to see that difference.
For AZA/VEN, it is relatively easier on the outcomes to test the addition of a drug, the
outcomes.
Not as good, even though they're better than other co-mutations.
So potentially, there is the possibility of doing a menin inhibitor and powering for OS.
For KMT2A, there is a clear benefit of high-intensity chemotherapy.
So whenever the paradigm study is discussed, I always get nervous about drawing a conclusion
that HMA/VEN is useful for KMT2A.
By far, high-intensity chemotherapy is better than HMA/VEN.
So any patient that could get high-intensity chemo should be getting high-intensity chemo.
There is potential advantage of adding venetoclax, and that's a separate discussion.
So primary endpoint, the gold standard according to the FDA is overall survival.
The main limitation of doing overall survival is that we're dealing with a good prognosis
leukemia.
So time to event is going to be long, magnitude of the effect needs to be high.
Event-free survival is an accepted endpoint now in the FDA.
Curative intent chemo.
So that is reasonable.
And then we're dealing with surrogate endpoints that are now accepted by the FDA for accelerated
approval.
So a definition of a surrogate endpoint by the FDA should be validated and reasonably
likely to predict clinical benefit, and in this case, overall survival.
So if this is met, drug gets accelerated approval, but it has to be verified and the full study
to get the full approval.
So for MPM1, it is the best example for a validated MRD endpoint.
And acute myeloid leukemia, there's excellent studies from the UK showing that at patient
level data, MPM1 positivity correlate with outcomes, and it is an independent marker
of prognosis.
If you lump a bunch of things in AML, you could track MPM1 MRD and still have a correlation
with overall survival.
So MPM1 meets what the FDA wants for a surrogate endpoint.
So back to the ACE of N, relatively more straightforward.
Primary endpoint.
Overall survival.
Maybe you can have a surrogate endpoint of a CR.
This is a study that would read relatively earlier.
You would have ACE of N, plus or minus menin inhibitor.
For young FIT, this is where there would be more of the challenge.
So seven plus three, plus or minus a menin inhibitor versus placebo.
Primary endpoint.
Overall survival is going to be a large study that's going to take a long time.
So no one is doing that.
Event-free survival is an endpoint accepted by the FDA for curative intent treatment.
You have to be careful about the FDA definition of an event-free survival.
So this would be lack of CR by day 42.
And if it is not met, that event happens day zero.
That's because there's variability in the treatment induction.
That's how the FDA defines an event.
CR MRD negative is accepted.
The FDA prefers DNA, even though they were hesitant at first about DNA versus RNA.
DNA is probably favored.
And even though a lot of the data on NPM1 is from peripheral blood, the majority of
what's being done is now bone marrow DNA.
So this is the possible structure.
The simplest is just to focus on the green.
So you take seven plus three and NPM1, maybe KMT2A, but you wouldn't power for KMT2A.
Exclude FLT3, VAF more than 5%.
Have an age stratification.
Addition of GO or addition of quesartanib, there could be more toxicity in older patients.
So that needs to be noted.
And then you do menin inhibitor plus placebo.
But because of the adjuvant treatment in lung cancer and the possibility of contribution
of phases in the clinical trial, the FDA now wants within each trial to have assessment
of phase specific contributions.
In other words, if you're having maintenance and you want an approval for the drug and
maintenance.
You want that contribution tested.
So in that case, the model would be adding a third arm where you have placebo as maintenance.
The pitfalls of all of this, when I think of what could go wrong, one could be clonal
evolution.
What if we target NPM1 and something else would relapse without NPM1?
I think it is less likely than FLT3 mutations.
I think this is one of the bigger problems of very specific FLT3 inhibitors where you
could target FLT3 and you have emergence.
I'm hoping for NPM1, it would be different.
We still have to learn that.
The other pitfall I think of when I look at these trials is underestimating the efficacy
in the control arm.
Just NPM1 does well with chemo.
What if we're basing our power calculations on cohorts where that NPM1 did it well and
we're going to test that the NPM1 do better.
So that's going to be an issue.
I don't think we have enough data on MRD negativity with a menin inhibitor.
What if there's an expansion of the treatment?
One of the transcript before a drop?
What if two cycles, which is established for chemotherapy is not the optimal timing for
that endpoint?
That is the pitfall, for example, of GILT versus mitostaurin where the time to MRD was
later, not at the time it was tested.
And the fourth bullet point is probably the main issue, which is what if we improve efficacy,
we target MRD, but also increase toxicity.
So that's why all the trials that are designing the regimens for addition of menin inhibitor,
we have to be careful about the dosing and selection.
And then ultimately, if we test something and the control arm is not great and it doesn't
lead to uptake of people using it, and I'm specifically talking about Azaven for KNT2A,
whereas the young patients should be getting intensive chemo and venetoclax, for example.
Nevertheless, I'm excited about all of this.
I think there are multiple pivoted trials and hopefully that would lead to an approval
of a menin inhibitor front line.
I think the majority of the clinical trials are very positive.
I think there are a lot of trials that are very positive.
I think the majority of the clinical trials have taken all these things into consideration.
I would like to see more data on MRD from the combination studies with menin inhibitors
so we clearly outline the dynamics of MRD response.
Thank you.